a russian court has found u.s basketball
player brittany griner guilty of drugs
possession and smuggling she has been
sentenced to nine years in jail the
sports star was arrested for carrying a
vape pen and cartridges in her luggage
which contained marijuana oil russian
authorities said the charges brought
against her were fully proven the u.s
says she's been wrongfully detained
before the sentencing greiner pleaded
with the judge for a favorable ruling
a short while ago deputy chief of
mission at the u.s embassy in moscow
elizabeth rood had this reaction outside
the courtroom
today u.s citizen athlete brittany
griner who is admired by millions of
fans in the united states as well as
here in russia was sentenced to nine
years in prison for nothing more than an
intentional oversight this is a
miscarriage of justice
the u.s department of state has
determined that miss greiner was
wrongfully detained nothing in today's
decision changes that determination
let's get more on this story from dw's
russia analyst constantine eggette
constantine are you surprised by this
verdict
claire not at all
according to statistics only one percent
of uh of sentences in russian courts
end in acquittal so britain grinder is
pretty much a standard case secondly it
doesn't really matter whether
these hash amples were planted on her
which is quite a frequent occurrence in
russia or she really carried them
ever since she was detained she became a
valuable hostage for the kremlin also a
very high profile one so uh this
decision was predestined you don't swap
do you don't exchange people in such
circumstances without very
high very very very sort of high profile
sentence so nine years is what i
actually predicted
and indeed we know there have been high
level diplomatic efforts between lavrov
and lincoln discussing an exchange of
russian and american prisoners are you
saying that this is what this case is
all about
yes although she was arrested just a
week before uh putin's second invasion
of
ukraine on the 24th of february but ever
since that day the stakes are very high
and of course uh putin has a very
long-standing dream he wants to get uh
victor boat a russian pilot
who is serving a very long sentence i
think it's a life sentence in the u.s
for arm smuggling uh he wants to get him
back he's become a kind of symbol uh in
russia as a symbol of someone who's
wrong wronged by the by america and uh i
think that grander
and another american paul whelan who is
also serving a jail sentence in russia
may be the pawns in this game you
mentioned victor boot he's convicted as
you say on much more serious grounds
than carrying cannabis oil um he's a
convicted arms trafficker dubbed the
merchant of death in the united states
do you think this would be a fair swap
well such swaps are never fair if you
look at the history of the cold war
these kind of dramatic exchanges of
spies on the bridge of spies in berlin
i think it was never uh
there was never a measure
of whether it's fair or not it's always
the the fairness if you wish is in the
eyes of the exchanger uh i think if both
sides think that their citizens
well should be back
then it's satisfying for them it's
there's never an objective measure of
fairness or not the crimes are not uh
comparable of course and russian courts
are not comparable to american courts
but well that's that's a reality and uh
one has to accept it i mean i'm sure joe
biden wants the americans back and i'm
sure that putin wants another propaganda
victory which uh grinders exchange uh
will probably grant him very soon it
does indeed bring back memories of the
cold war with relations between russia
and the united states at such a low
point are we likely to see more of this
kind of thing
yes it does i mean i think it will be
more difficult now with much fewer
americans traveling to
uh to russia i mean how you can kind of
grab them i mean as i said greiner was
uh
was arrested a week before the invasion
but i mean putin i think can always find
a way of tickling the us and the us will
always find a way of responding this is
indeed a bit like a cold war in the age
of social media
all right dw's russia analyst
constantine edgard thank you so much for
joining us with that update